[Music]
I'm not very
their thrown by my daughter and Milanese the
door downstairs it's the portrait the blay
the accused already another man
what happened I don't know
and is waiting for you
[Music]
I
[  Music]
I've been going to make
you die for years running
[Music]
I was about to see her paint her cylinder head h
they think you're a
drive campaign for something
what do you know about my future marriage
let's see it  is all i know about it too
when will you get married
i don't know if i will get married it's
because you can choose you
don't understand i understand when you
're embarrassed or dead shutters
really when you're troubled
[  Music]
I
how long is left and no
you're not
I we get by
m
what's the title by features of the
girl a little
[Music]